thrilled to have here on the rich eisen
show man who covers the lakers for the
athletic bill orem here on the rich
eisen show how are you bill
i'm doing great how are you ready what
was last night like 6 000 people in the
building
big time basketball game like uh like
old times huh bill you know what i'll
just say that that was the most fun i've
had at a basketball game
in more than 14 months you know somebody
who didn't cover the bubble
in person and you know who has kind of
been covering this this slog of a
regular season 72 games kind of
jammed into a few months no fans in the
building really no energy
um last night felt the closest to normal
it's been you had celebrities courtside
at staples center michael b
jordan was there with drake you know a
heavyweight battle between lebron and
steph curry
um and then it came down to the last
play which you'd love to see in a game
that is
that has stakes so you know i mean
there's so much in the world that is not
back to normal and 6 000 fans is a far
cry from what you know a rock and staple
center would normally
consist of but it was it was a heck of a
lot of fun i thought last night
and you know really sort of kind of set
the stage for what to expect
you know going forward from this lakers
team and and
and in this western conference battle
you know bill we were talking just at
the the top
of our show how the concept of you know
the clippers
uh apparently doing what they needed to
do
to make sure they were ensconced safely
in the fourth seed to avoid
any um any crossing of the paths with
the lakers into the last possible
moment and what they were doing and
whether they were really doing that or
not and the concept was you know hey
you want to see the lakers early uh as
opposed to late before they get their
sea legs under them it's tough to look
at that second half
and not think that the first half was
the half and
the the time where you wanted to get the
lakers and that maybe
last night's game was enough for the
lakers to get back into the groove
like last year what do you think about
that sense bill well i guess
you never know when the switch gets
flipped exactly
but but it did feel like obviously the
lakers needed some time to seal out
the warriors to kind of figure out what
playoff intensity looks like you know
one thing the lakers kept talking about
last night lebron mentioned this
is that the warriors had kind of been in
playoff scenarios
the last few games trying to lock down
the eight seed
whereas the lakers have kind of been
coasting you know i think they finished
the regular season on a five-game
winning streak
but you know they hadn't played games
with stakes in a really long time and i
think they were caught off guard by the
intensity
and discipline that the warriors started
the game with and i think the lakers
needed some time to catch up
you know but i don't know if i would go
so far as to say that one game
got lebron back in his groove and got
you know andre drummond acclimated and
got all the pieces
you know firing in the way they'll need
to when they get into those um
more meaningful uh playoff series or
excuse me i guess i should just say
those
those
more um intense playoff series where
they're gonna be you know need to beat
the phoenix suns four times and
and so on i just i felt like that game
was you know what it needed to be you
know they were
they they um they made the plays they
needed they they
they rose to the occasion in the right
moment i mean lebron was not very good
in that game by his own standard
until the fourth quarter um anthony
davis same like i think he's like five
of eleven uh to start the game and then
five
six uh in the fourth quarter something
like that like had a huge fourth quarter
it just is um you know the lakers were
good when they needed to be
but they're going to need to be good for
48 minutes against the suns
um and seven times so i do think there
is still a little bit of a bar the
lakers need to clear here
but i thought last night was was really
galvanizing for them and in in that they
haven't had
um they haven't really had sort of a
rallying cry this season you know the
bubble last year they were the most
dominant team they came together
were really connected and this year
they've kind of been a little more
fragmented and last night was kind of
the moment where it felt like maybe they
were starting to pull together just in
time yeah and then
vogel appeared to do what he needed to
do
uh as well and i'm wondering maybe that
is something that that is
of concern or or this may be the way it
goes
um moving forward or it was just needing
to do what he had to do to get out of
dodge last night with the match-ups and
in putting wes matthews and alex caruso
out there
in crunch time and removing the two
lakers that that
that were added uh prior to the season
and mid-season is the supposed big
upgrades over last year's championship
team
and dennis schroeder and and andre
drummond what did you make of that
bill horum well i mean kind of two
separate issues but
um they did go hand in hand i mean
trudeau is still working his way back
from the health and safety protocols
and did not look good last night i mean
i think he started one for 11 from the
field
got a little too i think a little too
aggressive offensively looking for a
shot
you know on some pretty critical
possessions in the last six minutes of
the game
uh was not was not really helping the
cause i don't think you'd say last night
and then andre drummond um that this is
going to be a match-up issue
for the lakers going forward there's
going to be some nights where you can
really
lean on him and and he can go bang in
the post with opposing bigs
but against teams that like to go small
he can be a liability and that's why you
saw him only play 17 minutes last night
you know it might have been you know 15
minutes too many frankly i mean
that's not a good matchup for andre
drummond and it felt like frank vogel
was trying to kind of thread
the needle there of you know trying to
keep andre drummond happy try to
establish him
on the inside early but also be ready to
go to anthony davis in the second half
he did with a.d at the five
and you know it's astute to point out
wesley matthews because the guy didn't
play in the first half
and he comes in and you know had stayed
ready and
you know made some really big plays
knocked down an early three in his
in his shift and you know to me that's
kind of what the lakers team needs to be
i mean they need to be nimble they need
to have guys who come off the bench and
you know not not play some nights and
then come up huge um
in in subsequent nights because they
don't have a set you know eight-man
rotation night in and night out like
you're gonna see from some of these
other contenders they probably have 10
or 11 guys
who are going to play in the playoffs um
but not every night and so those guys
understanding their roles and being
ready when they're called upon is going
to be absolutely vital
we've seen it from wesley matthews
actually a lot over the last few games
and what's interesting about him is if
you go back to when he was signed
all the all the chatter out of his camp
was that he signed with the lakers
for a defined role on a championship
team his role this year has been
anything but defined i mean we're
talking about a career starter
um you know who had you know been a
staple of every team he'd been on he's
been in and out of the lineup
um and he's kind of figured out how to
be this plug-and-play kind of superstar
when the lakers have needed him he's
made some huge plays and he's been a guy
that closed with
in um some close games uh in recent
weeks go back to that knicks game
and uh and then the the rockets game
after that he's he's been a
huge guy in the final minute of games
bill o'rem the lakers beat writer for
the athletic here
on the rich eisen show and you know bill
it's very fortunate that
we were able to get you to appear on
this show i don't usually go through
this
uh with the guest about how i i booked
the guests but
um i saw three of your numbers and i i
went for the middle one
and um i'm glad that it worked out
um so what's with that
quote from last night bill having been
around lebron as much as you have
give me that uh well there is i have a
cynical side
uh which i which i hesitate to share on
uh on a global platform like this
what the hell no please do please do
well i mean lebron said two things last
night one was that when he got the ball
the first thing he did was check out the
shot clock and the second thing he did
was realize that he saw three ribs and
picked one in the middle
and my the cynical side is like well how
could he read the shot clock
if he if he saw three baskets but uh
wouldn't there be three shot clocks
right wouldn't there be three
maybe he thought he saw it said point
nine three different times and that and
that expressed the urgency to him i i
you know lebron was hurting where we sit
at staples center
was right next to where he went down
after that foul by draymond
and that was a that was a pretty
gruesome play and i wasn't sure
actually frankly until after the game
what had um
what on him was hurting because he he
landed on his on his backside
his lit his leg kind of landed awkwardly
and it looked like he might have hit his
head on his way down and so when he's on
the ground
you know he was touching his head he's
touching his face you know later
realized you know he was checking for
blood and he was blinking to try to
you know make see what his vision was
like i didn't know if he might have a
concussion
um it was a pretty it was a pretty
gruesome play and it wasn't you know
now intent by you know by draymond it
was a hard foul to keep lebron from
scoring in a one-point game
but um you know i believe lebron like
lebron's eye
post game if you saw any of his post
game interviews it was grouping it
looked like he'd taken a punch
um so he was um he was hurting i you
know but it just
it just adds to the myth and and sort of
legacy of lebron james that
you know i mean i don't know how many
times over the course of a regular
season we see him shoot it from there or
see him shoot a step back from 35
and you know go off the front iron and
and you kind of roll your eyes and say
lebron like
not a good shot it's late in the game
there's 40 seconds left lakers are down
two and that's the shot he comes up with
you kind of like come on lebron like get
to the basket
but then in you know in that moment you
know he
he uncorked that one and again we're on
that end run that baseline watching the
ball head right to the basket i was like
that's going in and it just was it was
just an unbelievable
uh moment and again you know when you
talk about the lakers being defending
champions but not really playing like it
this season and not really having that
identity or that
you know that kind of moment to hang
their hat on that says
you are the lakers you have lebron you
are defending champions you have that
swagger
i feel like that moment um sort of
became that where the lakers could sort
of use that as their reset to say
we are here and we're ready for this
playoff run yeah i i don't doubt at all
that
i'm sure draymond got him in the eye
there's no
question there was no question in my
mind it was just you know
um and i i i haven't also been hit by
somebody like draymond green
in my entire life i have never been
contacted by anybody that size let alone
having somebody
with that hand size take one of their
fingers and you know hit me in the eye
you know and i i did sin as i'm sitting
there think that he was
while the concept of common foul or
flagrant foul was
under the hood to use the nfl phrase of
replay
that he might have been you know making
sure that there was uh
everyone was no even van gundy was
saying in the broadcast you know he's
making sure everybody sees how hurt he
is
and that might actually gain the shots
and possession which would have been so
huge at the time
um it's just him making that shot and
then looking at steph and pointing the
eye kind of like you know and i can't
even see
you know what i mean like it was it was
you know there's some athletes who will
talk about it and then their other
athletes will be like yeah
what are you talking about you know my
eyes i'll be fine you know what i mean
like
and lebron is the the former not the
latter and that's just part and parcel
of number 23.
there's no question about well he also
yeah and he also um
you know he also makes it very clear
that he feels you know disrespected
when he feels disrespected he's not
afraid to say it and you know you go
back to when the lakers won the
championship in the bubble
that was the first thing he said you
know this organization wants their
respect you know
genie bus wants to respect rob lincoln
wants his respect and i want my damn
respect too
you sit there and you're like you're
lebron james you got four mvps you know
four championships you are you know in
the conversation for the greatest of all
time like who doesn't respect lebron
james skip bailly ben at the same time
like there are there are
plenty of there are plenty of times that
we all sit there and think well is
lebron at the end of the road is lebron
going to be able to do this
right there is a lot of lebron
skepticism in the world and i do feel
like you know
moments like that he wants to make sure
that you appreciate what he's doing
because he is
i mean it goes without saying but he is
an all-time great who
summons these you know unreal
performances on a consistent basis and
especially
you know when the season um is on the
line and matters most i mean
if that shot doesn't go down last night
we might be talking about completely
different scenarios for the lakers the
lakers end up with their most favorable
playoff path that they could have out of
this
sort of range they're in um and you can
you can you can
sort of you know do some mental
gymnastics and they're in the finals
pretty easily
they lose last night and have to play
for the eight seed that road gets a lot
more treacherous
so uh before i let you go bill auram
first blush thoughts on the match-up
with the suns
what do you think well i i mean i saw
that
the the lakers opened as favorites in
the series which is just
i get it but it's it's kind of
unbelievable just to have a seven seed
favorite over at two
but it speaks to sort of how disjointed
the regular season was the fact the
lakers
are healthy just in time i don't think
the suns are a good match up excuse me i
don't think the lakers are good
let me get this right i don't think the
suns can match up with the lakers
you know anthony davis is is obviously a
bad matchup for most teams but i look at
the suns and i'm wondering who guards
anthony davis you know i love mikhail
bridges and i think he's you know one of
the young
stars in the league that we're going to
talk about for a long time as kind of
the guy who can do everything on the
floor
in a supporting role um but you throw
him at lebron who's left to try to
wrangle with anthony davis
you know dario saric to me is not an
answer and i just feel like the lakers
are going to be too physical
um and and are too good uh in transition
um you know the suns have had an amazing
season wouldn't count them out chris
paul
um you know the resurgence you know not
even a resurgence just the continuation
of everything he's done throughout his
career is is admirable and i think i
think people are sleeping on the suns as
a contender a little bit and see the sun
kind of as this
feel-good story that you know is maybe a
year away that this is a
a transitional step toward becoming a
contender
um but i you know i i don't know when i
look at it i just see the lakers having
too much
too much um too much inside for the sun
but
but we'll see i mean they were a game
off the best record in the league for a
reason and the lakers i mean
we haven't seen them at their best for
an extended period of time and
a playoff series is just a different
level of intensity and requires a
different level of being locked in
and that's something that the lakers
haven't had uh really since they left
the bubble back in october
bill thanks for the time thanks for the
thoughts um and thanks for your
reporting that i get to read
uh on the athletic and i look forward to
your coverage throughout the playoffs
and
keep looking for uh my call i appreciate
you coming on
i appreciate that so much thank you you
bet that's bill auram check him out
uh on the athletic and as you can hear
he knows his basketball
he knows his lakers hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here